Hi there, it's Marianne here. Before we dive into today's episode, I want to quickly let you know about something exciting that's happening right now. If you've ever wondered how to create income that works for you, rather than constantly trading your time for money, then you'll love the Race to Recurring Revenue Challenge with my business mentor, Lisa Johnson. This challenge is designed to help you build sustainable income streams. And whether you're an aspiring psychologist, a mental health professional, or in a completely different field,
the principles can work for you. There are also wonderful prizes to be won directly by Lisa herself. And if you join the challenge by my link, you can be in with a chance of winning a one-to-one hours coaching with me, Dr. Marianne Trent. Do you want to know more? Of course you do. Head to my link tree, Dr. Marianne Trent, or check out my social media channels, or send me a quick DM and I'll get you all the details. Right, let's get on with today's episode. Coming up in today's episode of the Aspiring Psychologist podcast, I am guiding you through two important steps that can help you think about weathering the storm on your journey
to becoming whatever type of aspiring psychologist you fancy being. If you're looking to become a psychologist Then let this be your guide With this podcast at your side You'll be on your way to being qualified It's the Aspiring Psychologist Podcast With Dr. Marianne Trent Hi, welcome along to the Aspiring Psychologist podcast. I'm Dr. Marianne Trent and I'm a qualified clinical psychologist. Here we are with another episode from the Marianne's Summer Soundbite series, which are going to be slightly shorter episodes than the standard episodes to help you to be able to continue engaging with your goals for learning and development in psychology over this summer period, when you might be a little bit busier. Don't worry, this isn't a permanent change to the format and the usual longer and guest episodes will be around over the summer and in the autumn again too.
Another series that you might well know and love is the free Compassionate Q&A series. Don't worry, that one is back for the 2023 season too. Here's all the details you need to know. So as you can see on your screen we have the first of those coming up on Monday the 4th of September 2023 and that starts at 6pm. A replay will of course be available too and the best place to find the replay is Dr. Marianne Trent on YouTube. The second of the sessions is Tuesday the 3rd of October 2023 also at 6 p.m. Again a replay is available. And the third and final session to support application season for the Declined Cyber also EdCycle is also a similar time of year
is going to be Tuesday the 7th of November 2023 at 6pm. So don't wait, don't delay, connect with me on socials now so that you can dive right in when the time comes. On LinkedIn I am Dr Marianne Trent, come and connect or follow. On Twitter I'm also Dr Marianne Trent, although on Twitter I can't see your comments because StreamYard and Twitter don't integrate properly, but if you want to just watch from Twitter, you absolutely can. On YouTube, I am Dr. Marianne Trent. My Facebook page is also Dr. Marianne Trent. And last but of course not the least, come and join my free Facebook community group which is called the Aspiring Psychologist Community with Dr Marianne Trent. I do always endeavour to get live on
Instagram as well but it's not quite so interactive because it means I have to get my phone rigged up behind my webcam. It's a little bit rustic but you absolutely should be able to catch it there too. And on Instagram and on Threads I am Dr. Marianne Trent. So let's not wish the summer away, let's make it a really mindful and enjoyable one. So let's take a look at another of Marianne's Summer Soundbites. You, my dear, have a unique perspective to offer you are the product of your own upbringing of those you've met those who spent time those you've been around those you've learned from those you've been in staff teams with those you have
been in school cohorts with you are the product of your experiences and all of those things have given you a unique perspective or maybe you've always felt a little bit like a black sheep in your collective and you've always felt like you think about things in a slightly different way but whatever position you find yourself to be in you are unique and you are special and I believe you have something rich and rewarding to be able to offer your clients maybe even shape building growth services interventions research and important things that are going to make a real difference to people's lives around the country around the UK
and the world for that matter and that all comes from you that comes from your commitment and your determination and the unique way that you see the world and the problems that you will navigate and how you come up with ideas to get around them to overcome them makes me think about the famous book going on a bear hunt no we can't go over it we can't go under it we can't go under it. We can't go around it. We have to go through it. And, you know, you will find your own ways to get over, round, down, under the problems. Or, you know, to have a real errorless learning approach where you eradicate the problem cropping up in the first place. You have the opportunity to bring fresh perspectives and
fresh insight and fresh, you know, determination and enthusiasm to the career, to the field. And I know when I was in my second year of training, my supervisor, who rarely managed to break both of her arms. At the same time, I recently broke one of my arms. So sending lots of love to you. She said to me during a supervision session, just how much she had enjoyed supervising assistants and trainees, because she felt that she gained and learned so much from them, the way that they saw the world and the things that excited and delighted them and, you know, drove them, their passions, the things they were interested in, the research they've done and the clinical areas and populations they've previously worked with.
So, yeah, don't forget to really consider yourself as unique. Don't necessarily feel like just because, you know, you're not in agreement with someone else in the team or perhaps even your supervisor that you're wrong or that you need to squish that in some way. So sometimes we need to be able to play the game. But of course, if you've got concerns about anything, then you need to raise those in the appropriate way. But you know, it's okay to explore the way you see the world in supervision and to think about cultivating your own research and clinical interests. Let's take a quick break and I'll be back along with the next of our learning points. Thank you. Welcome back. So the second of today's points for consideration is thinking about learning as a continuous journey. It's a lifelong journey as
well. So it might feel that you, you know, the time is not quite right for you at the moment. So even among the people that I did my undergraduate psychology degree with in the late 90s and early 2000s, there's recently been people who have started to think that maybe a career in professional psychology might be for them and so it's never too late as you might well remember from our recent podcast episodes with Fiona and with Mark when it's your time and you're ready for the next step you can always climb back on board and the rich way that you will have learned about life and clients and how to tackle and overcome difficulties and also how to better engage service users from your time doing different
career pursuits is likely to be invaluable, not just to the clients you work with, but also to your peers who end up being in your cohort and ultimately in your teams. Stay curious, you know, commit yourself to expanding your knowledge and your skills. If a training opportunity quats up, ask if you can do it. If there might even be a training budget in your department, how you could put in a bid or a request to be able to fulfill some of your learning objectives. And this is where your yearly appraisal, if you have one, can be really useful too. So I hope you've found today's episode of Marianne's Summer Sandbites useful. If you like the kind of things that I've got to offer, do check out the Aspiring Psychologist membership.
I hope you're being kind to yourself. Hope you're having a really lovely summer. I will look forward to catching up with you for the next episode of the aspiring psychologist podcast which is around for Monday 6am thank you so much for being part of my world and be kind to yourself if you're looking to become a psychologist Then let this be your guide With this podcast at your side You'll be on your way to being qualified
It's the Aspiring Psychologist Podcast With Dr. Marianne Trent My name's Jana and I'm a trainee psychological well-being practitioner. I read the Clinical Psychologist Collective book. I found it really interesting about all the different stories and how people got to become a clinical psychologist. It just amazed me how many different routes there are to get there and there's no perfect way to become one. And this kind of filled me with confidence that no I'm not doing it wrong and put less pressure on myself. So if you're feeling a bit uneasy about becoming a clinical psychologist I'd definitely recommend this just to put yourself at ease and everything will be okay but trust me you will not put the book down once you start. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.